alright this is just a real quick intro
you're about to get a jump cut and see
me wearing different stuff in a
different setting and everything else
this is just an intro because I'm going
to keep going on about comic books that
I think should be movies but probably
won't get made the reason that you're
getting this little intro is when I shot
the original video I had intended it to
be one long ramble I decided to break it
up into three parts so this is part two
let's go to something a little more
obscure and I'm going to put in my vote
for far west by Richard Moore this thing
as far as I'm concerned as it is camera
ready it is a fun exciting pg-13 level
romp with funny dialogue a strong female
lead great action of fun and setting and
it's if you can't guess from looking at
it that's an elf that's a dragon that's
a classic western setting and that
pretty much sums it up you've got your
basic fantasy tropes you've got elves
you've got trolls you've got goblins
you've got dragons in a western setting
with trains and the and the ghost towns
and minds and and all of those classic
things and it all mixes together really
really really well and this I think you
know the dragon app do CGI but stick
with practical effects for most of this
at the very least for things like the
trolls and if they could find a way to
pull off Phil who is a the partner in
this and he is a he's a bipedal talking
bear but if they can pull him off
practically I'd appreciate that too
though if you got to go see G on him
I'll accept it and you know actually
speaking of fill the bear I am gonna do
one tiny bit of dream casting on here no
matter how they do Phil whether he is
practical effect whether he's CGI no
matter what John Goodman needs to voice
it don't even argue with me on that this
blend really works probably never going
to happen though two reasons first of
all this particular book it's as much as
I love it it's a little bit obscure but
even looking beyond that because there
are some obscure comic books have been
turned into very good movie
men in black was a very obscure comic
book before it became a fantastic movie
and a lousy sequel than an okay third
installment be obscure doesn't
automatically put it off the table what
does take it off the table is the fact
that the last few times Hollywood has
tried to blend sci-fi or fantasy
elements into Western we got wild wild
west and cowboys and aliens which was a
disaster and exercise in mediocrity
respectively neither voice did
particularly good at the box office and
both of which were expensive which this
unfortunate would also be I'm just in
love with Richard more stuff now
admittedly if we're going to stick with
him we could go for something a little
bit more camera-friendly and that would
probably be bone yard although if we're
ever gonna do boneyard I think that has
got to be done animated because it's so
stylized to his his way that he draws
these these monsters and these creatures
that are in it this one if they ever did
it should be animated this you could do
this live action and it would work so
there you go until part 3 comes along
this council is adjourned